ninja was once the
face of streaming esports and gaming
[Music]
for the general public he was a window
into streaming and gaming culture
is this a little bit a little bit pull
there it is
boom but in the last little while things
have changed benny i wasn't one in three
at the time you
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about stay sober kid back in his
fortnight glory days ninja tried his
hardest to be squeaky clean and family
friendly
a lot of the people here that are here
in front of us are our viewers
which is what actually amazes me about
you tyler that you're up here because
most of your viewers are outside because
of the age restrictions
but those days are long gone and ninja
streamer persona took a drastic turn
why the are you baiting me raised what
are you doing
let's face it we all wanted the real
ninja
and it looks like that's exactly what we
got
you're so dope with you guys
ninja was once the undisputed king of
twitch
this year alone you stream for 3 400
hours
that's 142 days worth of gaming
wow so when he signed a multi-million
dollar exclusive streaming deal with
mixer
the gaming community was stunned ninja
left twitch
you're lying no way dude
no way like what the [ __ ] man
ninja's gonna move over to mixer
unfortunately the move cost ninja a big
part of his viewer base
how many viewers are across the board do
we have right now
i don't even know man probably probably
like what 500
brother you i mean that's like all a
mixer right
but mixer did provide ninja with a
steady and reportedly
pretty sizable paycheck and it wasn't
just him ninja's mixer contract created
a precedent for other streamers out
there
a way to keep their income from being at
the mercy of their fans
the move was good good career decision
for him and a fantastic
[Music]
decision whether or not he knows it or
planned for it
um for the rest of the gaming community
and if you thought ninja was rolling in
it before
the mixer deal he was now annoyingly
rich
it was funny man i actually talked [ __ ]
to someone the other day in a stream who
was just roasting my league of legends
gameplay i told him that i could buy his
stanley tree
but even though mixer signed the biggest
streamer in the world
it still wasn't enough to compete with
twitch
yesterday mixer announced that they'll
be ceasing their operations
completely microsoft's answer to twitch
and the organization that signed shroud
and ninja
to multi-million dollar exclusivity
deals is no more
surprisingly though mixer's demise
turned out to be a good thing for ninja
i mean for ninja and shroud bro i mean
that
that to be honest with you in their
position was almost
best case scenario they get their
contract money they don't have to stream
there and they can go wherever they want
now that might seem like the ultimate
happy ending ninja and his fans
reunited on twitch but along with his
return to twitch
came a return to something else i
realized that i had the most incompetent
narcissistic stick squad of a bard
support lane
and i was stuck with him in lane for 15
minutes in his early days
ninja developed a reputation for being
kind of
the [ __ ] toxic say to me you little [ __ ]
this game dude and now that he was back
on twitch
he reverted to his old toxic ways you
know what's funny bro
if xucc were popping off right now right
if this was like an extreme like dude
everything exactly right there's a
single
person like yo yo hey xbc chill out bro
calm down dude
hey relax not a single person in this
lobby
tell me i'm wrong tell me i'm wrong
money and fame
changed ninja he now had access to an
insane amount of fans
funds and for the first time in years
freedom
to act exactly the way he wanted family
friendly image be damned
i literally told you to stop
i said no don't don't
don't and you try you're so
bad many people accuse ninja of having
become an out-of-touch
millionaire who regularly posts bizarre
tweets and goes on toxic rants in-game
and he's sitting here as i'm getting
pumped for 170 damage
i'm gonna pick out him i mean just
listen to some of these
insane takes he's had on twitter i'm in
the middle of carrying a league of
legends game
about to close it out and my brawless
wife brings me a sandwich
not asked for with chips as i get a
double kill bot lane
so how's your day going the phrase it's
just a game
is such a weak mindset you are okay with
what happened
losing imperfection of a craft when you
stop getting angry after losing
you've lost twice there's always
something to learn
and always room for improvement never
sell
i'll never understand how college and
nfl football teams allow kickers that
just
miss kicks i feel like there has to be
pools of kickers in the usa that
won't miss simple kicks or snappers that
won't mess the snaps
i don't know man it just seems so silly
with a lot of opinions on this
but there is more to ninja these days
than just your run-of-the-mill
money turned celebrity into a maniac
story ninja's sharp if
toxic wit and ragey behavior was what
made him a gaming superstar in the first
place
now i had a jump head that i could have
used man those kids were so
bad watching someone completely lose it
can be pretty entertaining
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up in the background
and watching someone as rich and famous
as ninja froth at the mouth over a bad
game of
league can be hilarious cat blitz
quit the game you're trash you're awful
you're so stupid but
being toxic online wasn't the only thing
ninja was doing with his time
he doesn't have a choice dvd members
they know it and they're just stamina
but ninja finds the head of one ninja
able to find two
he's looking for the third and he makes
it ninja was serious about learning
valrant and getting better at the game
he joined a team and even went as far as
hiring a coach and paying his teammates
a salary to play competitively
is he a ninja oh he's a ninja
eventually though ninja lost interest in
the game and so
after putting in an honest effort ninja
quit valorent and
returned to streaming you know i told
the team that like i know i wanted them
to find a replacement for me
like i feel like such a big weight has
been lifted off my shoulders dude
because now i can stream whenever i want
i can i can get off right now if i
wanted to literally i mean i've been
streaming for four five inches for five
hours i can hop off right now and just
spend the rest then i would just
i would have had to have gotten off 26
minutes ago and been ready for scrims
with all the money in the world and a
pandemic putting everybody else on a
lockdown
all ninja really seems to want to do is
just play video games all day
and that's kind of relatable
set it up set it off oh my god look at
it oh man
chad this is what you give the other
team false confidence when they picked
daddy carry right
and then you just let morg rail him
to a certain extent it's easy to
understand why ninja would revert back
to his baser instincts
he has a ton of money no company telling
him what to do and nowhere to go while
the world is shut down
he went back to being the basement
dwelling lizard gamer that we all
are at heart but the crazy thing is that
it's
actually working for him ninja's
viewership saw a bit of a rebound ever
since he switched to league and let his
toxicity run loose
he didn't roam he wasn't helping anyone
do anything else
and then sit back and be like well i
i didn't feed anyone i didn't feed
anyone
because they didn't do anything either
bro some people may think he's
having some sort of meltdown but this
isn't ninja's first rodeo
hell he might even be putting on an act
either way though
he's laughing all the way to the bank
don't apologize guys i was happy you
guys are having fun i was pissed i
wasn't
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages